[Applause]
I so insisted spectacular place not only
does Ison have a boiling River
they've even got this volcano you can
literally descend into my name is
Anthony Russo and I'm a geothermal
scientist and Explorer with National
Geographic
so when Coors Light National Geographic
asked me what's your next no question
Iceland
these are the areas that we want to hit
so we'll be in Reykjavik first but then
the volcano that we go into is around
about there this place is just a
wonderland for anything geologic so in
2009 my plan was to move to Northern
Iceland I had gotten a full ride
scholarship to what was my dream school
then I met Sofia and that's where the
dream school lost out to the dream girl
I was worried that we'd never make it to
Iceland I thought this is too good to be
real this is not a cave it's a lava tube
this was created by a river of flowing
lava melts down deep enough to where
it's the cool cool cool cool cool
kind of like a freezing River you'd
really see where the lava was just
flowing through here Oh kiss going wow
look at this
four of us in the direction which the
lava was fun Oh welcome to your tropical
getaway
earth is alive there's heat there's hot
water flowing through cracks and faults
in the earth constantly moving
constantly changing and the only way to
truly understand this by looking at the
rock type this is not that's Iceland's
boiling River we're in a mecca for all
things geothermal right now God look
it's bubbling you can see it from here
so what's crazy about boiling rivers and
this is what gets me so fired up about
them it's so rare to see these
ecosystems you need for things to just
align perfectly you need a tremendous
source of heat a tremendous source of
water the right plumbing system to get
all of this hot water from deep in the
earth up to the surface and on top of
that you can't have anything cool it
down if all this was underneath laisure
they wouldn't get the chance to form
into the boiling River that you see down
there this is exactly what kind of stuff
we want a sample we're here to take the
first sample from the rekha dilute
geothermal system and it is just gushing
bubbling hot oh it's getting hot it's
getting hot and hot oh this is awesome
this is what expirations all about god I
love them
[Music]
yes look it's bubbling up over there
this is just a geothermal Wonderland and
that is the original geyser actually we
get our word geyser from the original
Icelandic work Jason that's right Jason
yeah they say it's 80 to 100 degrees C
the temperature gets so high that that
water flashes and then you see that guys
are shooting up oh it's bubbling again
yep okay so that's a Cap'n yeah
that was incredible that was really high
I didn't expect it to go that high
actually how well go into a Hidden
Valley the hidden waterfalls what they
called it
[Music]
[Music]
we flew over the coast we just really
show just the vastness of everything all
of the different landscapes
[Music]
I cannot believe we're on a glacier
right now not only on a glacier but a
glacier that's on a volcano it's like a
frozen river our guides took us to the
center of the glacier and this is really
a land of fire ice
[Music]
everything that we've seen here has been
so awesome but the next place we're
going to that's the reason we're here
we're walking in to something that to
the best of my knowledge you can do
nowhere else on planet Earth we're going
into the volcano a long way down ladies
a long way up
never have I gotten to descend due to a
volcano like this
4,500 years ago roughly this volcano
erupted
the magma chamber emptied out and we're
standing in it now the palette of
oranges and yellows and right it's just
incredible our very definition of beauty
comes from nature I think to be human
means to push boundaries we need to go
further
this has been the adventure of a
lifetime I can't wait to play with next
[Music]
[Music]